to put some terms on the table so we
understand them
you nonchalantly say it's always the on
average expanding every year the money
supply is expending every year by seven
percent that's a bad thing that's a
universally a bad thing
it's awful but I guess I guess to be
precise uh it's the currency
I mean my money uh I would say money is
monetary energy or economic energy and
the economic energy has to find its way
into a medium so if you want to move it
rapidly as a medium of exchange has to
find its way into currency but the money
can also flow into property like a house
or gold if the money flows into property
it'll probably hold its value much
better if the money flows into currency
right if you had put a hundred thousand
dollars in this house
you would have 305x return over 92 years
but if you would put the money a hundred
thousand dollars into safe deposit box
and buried in the basement
you would have lost
99.7 of your wealth over the same time
period
so
um so the the expansion of the currency
crates uh crates a massive inefficiency
in the society what I'll call an
adiabatic lapse it's what we're doing is
we're bleeding
the civilization to death right the
antibiotic antibiotic what's that word
that's adiabatic loss adiabatic right
and aerospace engineering you want to
solve any problem they they start with
the phrase assume an adiabatic system
and what that means is a closed system
okay so I've got it I've got a container
and in that container no air leaves and
no air enters no energy exits or enters
so it's a closed system
so you got the closed system lapse okay
okay I'm gonna use a there's a leak in
the ship I'm gonna use a physical
metaphor for you because you're the
Jujitsu right like yeah like you got 10
pints of blood in your body and so
before your next uh workout I'm gonna
take one pint from you
now you're going to go exercise but
you're one part you've lost 10 percent
of your blood
okay you're not going to perform as well
it takes about one month for your body
to replace the red blood platelets so
what if I tell you every month you got
to show up and I'm going to bleed you
yeah okay so uh so if I'm draining the
energy I'm drain I'm draining the blood
from your body you can't perform if you
adiabatic lapse is when you go up in
altitude every thousand feet you lose
three degrees
you go 50 000 feet you're 150 degrees
colder than sea level that's why you you
know you look at your
instruments and instead of 80 degrees
your minus 70 degrees why is the
temperature falling temperatures falling
because it's not a closed system it's an
open system as the air expands the
density Falls right the inner the energy
per uh per cubic whatever you know Falls
and therefore the temperature Falls
right the Heat's falling out of the
solution
so
when you're inflating let's say you're
inflating the money so the currency
supplied by six percent you're sucking
six percent of the energy
out of the fluid that the economy is
using to function so the currency this
kind of ocean of currency that's uh
that's a nice way for the economy to
function it's the most kind of uh it's
being inefficient when you expand the
money supply but it's uh
look at the liquid I'm trying to find
the right kind of adjective here it's
how you you do transactions at a scale
of billions currency is the asset we
used uh to move monetary energy around
and you could use the dollar or you
could use the peso or you could use the
bowl of our Selling Houses and buying
houses is much more inefficient uh or
like uh you you can't transact between
billions of people with houses yeah
properties don't make such good mediums
of exchange they make better stores of
value and they they have utility value
if it's a if it's a ship or a house or
or a plane or a bushel of corn